I work at a place called MIT Media Lab
where I'm surrounded by amazing
researchers doing truly groundbreaking
work just in our group we have recorded
the light as is passing in front of the
camera for this we have put together a
camera with half a trillion frames per
second and that's why you can see the
pulses of light passing through the coke
bottle we have image hidden objects
around the corner and reconstructed them
in 3d for this you are using the same
technology to measure the time that it
takes for the light to scatter around
the corner and come back to the camera
and that's why we can reconstruct this
mannequin around the corner the future
cars can use this technology to sense
around the corner and avoid collision so
how do we come up with these ideas well
sometimes we get inspired by sci-fi for
example we're inspired by Star Trek
tricorder which is engineering Lee
ridiculous and far-fetched what's
interesting though is that as we move
toward this imaginary artistic concept
we realize so many realistic
possibilities that open up the same
spectroscopy technique that might be
used to detect diseases can be used to
do other things today I'm reporting such
other things I'm reporting for the first
time a technology that is capable of
reading through a closed book with
electromagnetic waves at terahertz
frequencies here's a recorded data set
so this is the letter T on the first
page you can ignore the name of the
algorithms for now now we are reading
the letter H on the second page through
the first page so all the character
extraction and recognition is done with
computer and without human supervision
the characters are written with pencil
are on paper pages so now we're at we
are at page four with letter L page five
the letter A have in mind that some of
these characters are even occluded by
the characters at front pages
you're using the best of both math and
physics to read as deep as possible so
this is like reading through a closed
book with telehealth technology which
can be very valuable for inspecting
antique artworks and documents I don't
want to talk about the details of this
technology today what I want to talk
about is the cycle that generates all of
these ideas which is the cycle between
art and science basically we go back and
forth between a realistic engineering
world and an imaginary artistic one to
find well the state of the art let me
take you to recycle with few examples
let's start with sars holoprojector this
is a concept that is taken from science
to sci-fi dennis gabor invented the
holography at 1950s and the concept was
far-fetched to sci fi at 1970s I was
sitting in an optics class in my masters
when this idea this concept came back to
me and I kept asking myself does this
even make sense because you know the
light propagates on a straight path in a
uniform medium like mid air and there's
really no way you can bounce it around
like this amid air with conventional
methods so this idea at its core comes
down to making a point in mid-air to
glow like a pixel or forcing it to
bounce or scatter light which is very
difficult very very difficult being a
naive master student at the time I
decided to do exactly that I decided I
decided to take a concept from art world
to real engineering world so I studied a
bunch of books and optics and I finally
decided to use acoustic fields or sound
to deflect light in midair through an
effect called acousto-optic effect I
later discovered that on the other side
of the planet another nice scientists in
Japan had decided to use strong electric
fields to ionize the air and make it
glow unfortunately I have to tell you
that well we both kind of failed the
acoustic field that my method requires
is so large that you would go deaf
before even seeing a single
pixel and for Japanese version you
better wear safety goggles for watching
even these few pixels the reason that
these methods don't work it is that you
don't know how to do them efficiently
you don't know how to amplify them and
there's just so much that we don't know
it's hard to realize a far-fetched idea
of a concept artist with realistic
measures we engineers are quite good at
going from art two science we can take a
constant apart and say if it works or
not for us engineers practicality is the
most credible asset we cannot bear to
fly as far as a concept artist we will
lose our credit in our community
engineering world is rigorous
reproducible and quantitatively precise
but to think creatively and for being
visionary you really need to go both
ways and that's what you're not very
good at in fact we're not even trained
to operate in the concept world these
are the skills that concept artists
develop very well so I decided to learn
a little bit of concept art to exercise
my imaginations and explore this
imaginary world to give you a taste
let's imagine like a concept artist here
let's imagine that we could control the
path of light in midair fine here you
have your Star Wars whole projector mr.
iron man but a casa wireless wouldn't
stop here if we could control the path
of light in mid-air we could grab the
light from a very large area and focus
it to a single point to generate energy
simply by popping out the necessary
sound pattern if you could control the
path of light in mid-air your camera
wouldn't need a lens anymore it would
have an acoustic phase array instead
that would allow you to generate any
type of lensing effect your desire in
front of the sensor so when the new lens
comes to the market you simply download
the signal and fit it to the array
basically the optics as we know it would
end compact solar cars compact solar
planes you name it it will be possible
only because thank you i have one fan
here haha only if you
only if we could control the path of
light in midair but well we can't or
maybe I should say you just don't know
how to do it well with these
visualizations though what we do know
now is all the surrounding possibilities
we have materialized our concept with
these pictures your sketches can contain
your imaginations and allow you to edit
your dreams as if they actually exist
this is what helps the cycle generate
ideas it encourages making invalid
assumptions to see and analyze beyond
impossible this imaginary possibilities
then form the direction of the future
work alright let's practice a little bit
more let's take a more tangible problem
say sleeping for example everyone likes
to get a better sleep right let's assume
that the problem with sleeping is
because of the beds so the beds are not
doing what they were supposed to be
doing the ideal sci-fi solution would be
a human capsule that would constantly
rejuvenate your body you can see my
version of it on the left and your
cindy's in the movies like the matrix
and the avatar but that's way far first
I mean if you go back to reality today
and mattress is just a dumb piece of
foam so so what if we step it up a
little how about the matter is that is a
little bit more dynamic well that
actually exists in a different context
so we need to get imaginary again how
about a flexible flexible exoskeleton
that moves very slowly during the night
to rejuvenate your body so when you wake
up in the morning it is as if you have
done a very slow yoga the entire night
well let's say you like that idea so now
it's time to go back to the research
mode and you know learn about the
similar works and relevant technologies
you have to go through the cycle again
and again but with more details and
sharper focus to finally get to the
right solution all right to simplify
we're going from our to science you have
to find the connections to reality and
work your way through those points to
both the concept into reality here if
you have a more diverse background
you're ahead of the game you gotta if
you have a broader that background
you're ahead of the game so this is
where your degree is supposed to be
helping you all right ok so when going
from science to art you need to imagine
out loud you need to let everything down
on the paper without being let's say
engineering Lee judgmental here you need
to be that's true here you need to be
here you need to be artistic you need to
let everything down on the paper and you
need to know visualization techniques to
crystallize your imaginations the same
cycle can be used for business or any
type of problem it's just a expansive
constructive way of thinking so no
matter what you do for your living don't
let your imaginations and ideas
evaporate away collect them and put them
down like an artist and look at them
like an engineer and trust me you will
learn amazing things the state of the
art is literally a resonance between art
and science it's a dance between reality
and imaginations I've had a lot of fun
watching this dance what conceptualizing
all of these ideas new gadgets new
technologies new ways to think and
express yourself the impossible is not
as far as you think and the
possibilities are endless only if you
dare to imagine out loud thank
you